dans un théâtre bernard pinet dans son
élément cet habitant de noisy le roi âgé
de 66 ans a fait de la scène sa vie tout
a commencé très jeune dans son sud natal
une quarantaine d'années avant sa venue
dans les yvelines
donc j'étais premier en lecture
c'étaient les seules fois où j'étais
premier et henri citation alors il y a
une explication probablement à tout cela
je suis d'une famille du sud qui avait
une grande bouche qui s'exprimer haut et
fort quelques années plus tard son franc
parler des rencontres le motive à monter
à paris à l'âge de 20 ans avec quelques
francs en poche
aujourd'hui l'yvelinois totalise plus de
80 films à son actif qu'un tas du bien
aucun bien s'étoffer
tu changes de victimes tombées bernard
pinet donne également la réplique dans
trente spectacles l'un de ses rôles
phares le dîner de cons dans la pièce le
noiséens joue le rôle du contrôleur du
fisc lucien cheval c'est un énorme
succès on le joue au sens plus de 170
fois dans les plus grands théâtres les
plus beaux théâtres de france de suisse
de belgique nous avons joué ici au
théâtre montansier et puis c'est zénith
qui était inattendu ont passé entre
johnny hallyday et starmania
après le dîner de cons bernard pinet
décide de monter des concepts de théâtre
seul en scène le comédien créé
interprète pétanque et sentiments il
pièce se joue est 300 fois et qui a
participé à quatre festival d'avignon et
à des mois molière à versailles
ben écoute tout d'abord je vais
réattaquer le sport afone les boules je
vais essayer de jouer à la pétanque au
moins une fois par semaine
c'est mon gros bébé je l ai vu naître du
premier mot sur le papier je les ai vus
grandir
je les ai vus se transmuter muet malgré
ses succès bernard pinet ne veut pas
entendre parler de retraite cette année
en 2019 l'artiste revient une nouvelle
fois au festival d'avignon pour défendre
son nouveau projet apocalypse
républicaine une pièce selon scène sur
l'actualité politique et sociétale
symboliquement c'est puissant c'est fort
que la première lecture mondiale ait
lieu ici dans ce festival pour moi
j'étais important vrai que le premier
drapeau soient plantés ici
ce nouveau projet écrit pendant un an
est présenté aujourd'hui en première
lecture
au fait vous connaissez la différence
entre un train et un homme politique
non le train quand il déraille il
s'arrête lui même sur la lecture je me
l'imaginé je trouve que le projet très
intéressant voilà déjà pour pour lui
pour nous et peut-être pour d'autres ça
va pas trop réagi pour les niveaux de
lecture non plus parce que c'est pas
matière sur une lecture à a généré des
reer ou d'aider des émotions fortes mais
ce que j'ai entendu après me satisfait
pleinement bien sûr je crois que je vais
continuer bernard pinet espère désormais
monter son spectacle et le présenter en
2020 un festival d'avignon et joué dans
des films et séries sur les prochains
mois la retraite attendra